and we begin with correspondent Kevin
quark near the president's Florida
resort
good evening Kevin evening my call at
operational security call it secret but
by any definition the president's visit
to Afghanistan was a very welcome
surprise
for some of the many American troops
stationed abroad this Thanksgiving
holiday I hope everyone enjoyed the
fantastic meal after a secret 13 hour
flight some 50,000 feet above the frigid
wild blue a warm welcome in Afghanistan
President Trump surprise trip to see US
service personnel this Thanksgiving
holiday a welcome treat for troops on a
day when we all pause to give thanks
this evening as millions of families sit
down at their dinner tables back home
they'll be saying a prayer for the men
and women serving our nation in
Afghanistan and deployed all around the
globe it was in many respects like what
we have seen before plenty of photos a
bit of good-natured banter and of course
serviced by the commander-in-chief to
those who in being here have already
sacrificed so much his remarks hit on
familiar themes to a stronger than ever
military the removal of terrorists from
the battlefield and the like the
president also used his first trip to
Afghanistan to meet his presidential
counterpart announcing the u.s. and
Taliban have restarted peace talks with
the u.s. insisting on a ceasefire the
Taliban wants to make a deal and we're
meeting with them and we're saying it
has to be a ceasefire and they didn't
want to do a ceasefire but now they do
want to do as he's fire this after the
u.s. abruptly withdrew from bilateral
peace talks in September and the
president said he was following through
with his campaign promises to draw down
American troop levels quote
substantially to about eighty six
hundred that's a number that people are
talking about yes
yeah it is for now and then we could do
much more than Eliezer you can go much
further than that keenly aware that the
future will fend for itself this was a
day instead to remain very much in the
present a chance to cap a journey
shrouded in secrecy with a very public
declaration of support there's nowhere
I'd rather celebrate this Thanksgiving
than right here with the toughest
strongest best and bravest warriors on
the face of the earth my qs4 strength in
Afghanistan's right now between 12 and
13,000 that's actually down a couple of
thousand since this time a year ago the
president making it very clear today the
US will remain in the country unless
there was a deal where we achieve total
victory Mike pretty cool visit from the
commander-in-chief
Kevin cork live in Florida Kevin thanks
a lot